[Music]
the United States military is always
looking for new ways to create super
soldiers they use performance enhancing
and mind-altering drugs they're
currently experimenting with brain
implant technology they've even explored
genetic engineering to try and breed the
perfect Soldier but those are nothing
compared to what happened in 1983 when
Lieutenant Colonel Wayne McDonald
submitted a very unusual and detailed
report to US Army intelligence it was
called analysis and assessment of
Gateway process this is a step-by-step
guide on how to achieve an out of body
experience for the purpose of
intelligence gathering but Colonel
McDonald's report went much further than
that an advanced Gateway participant
could not just project their
Consciousness to a different place they
could pull their Consciousness
completely out of this reality they
could travel anywhere in the universe
and at any point in time the report
revealed that our universe doesn't
actually exist it's a construct created
by our mind by using the Gateway process
you can exit the construct and see
reality for what it really is the
30-page Gateway report was immediately
classified for one simple reason anyone
can learn to do it even you
foreign
McDonalds analysis and assessment of
Gateway process gets right to the point
there are alternate states of reality
and other dimensions that exist outside
our physical world and outside of time
itself
it sounds like I'm gonna need a Brink
bucket for this one oh yeah this is the
strangest military report I've ever read
I'm surprised it's not still classified
according to the report we can use the
Gateway process to access other
dimensions now if you think that sounds
paranormal or like new age mumbo-jumbo
you're not alone even Colonel McDonnell
was aware that this was the impression
his report would give so he starts off
by grounding his research in science
McDonald consults itzak bentoff a
well-respected biomedical engineer to
help him understand the physical aspect
of the process he uses quantum mechanics
to describe the nature of human
consciousness and he employs both
classical and theoretical physics to
explain the out of body phenomenon but
most importantly the report gives
step-by-step instructions on how to have
a Gateway experience follow these
instructions and you can learn to
actually project visit other dimensions
and even slip in and out of time this is
why the military was drawn to it and
studied it for years if the United
States would train a unit of psychic
spies that could project their
Consciousness anywhere unnoticed that
would be very effective at Gathering
intelligence still McDonald knew his
report would be difficult to believe but
he really thought it could be done there
is a sound rational basis in terms of
physical science parameters for
considering gateway to be plausible in
terms of its essential objectives
intuitional insights of not only
personal but of a practical and
professional nature would seem to be
within bounds of reasonable expectations
um
my brain bucket
Philip
face it is you better have a spare
bucket handy Gateway process is a
training system developed in the 70s by
the Monroe Institute in Virginia current
McDonald along with other military
personnel went through the week-long
training process that anyone can do even
today but the Gateway report ended with
a final warning that nobody really
expected because this method is
accessible to anyone Colonel McDonnell
warned that the military should be
prepared for encounters with intelligent
and non-friendly entities that could
exist outside the boundaries of time and
space in other words a psychic war
even though anyone can learn the Gateway
method you can't just snap your fingers
and Escape reality there is some
foundation work you have to do first
well no matter what
ring ain't no such thing as a free lunch
right you have to learn relaxation
techniques meditation and extreme Focus
you also have to set all doubt aside and
let your mind be open to a completely
new way of thinking only once you master
these techniques can you begin to
comprehend the true nature of reality
your life the Earth the universe and
everything in it is an illusion created
by your mind solid matter in the strict
construction of the term simply does not
exist rather atomic structure is
composed of oscillating energy grids
surrounded by other oscillating energy
grids which orbit at extraordinarily
high speeds
there is no solid matter everything that
exists is a form of energy vibrating at
extremely fast frequencies from the
largest objects in the universe down to
atoms and subatomic particles and
everything in between it's all energy
the point to be made is that the entire
human being brain Consciousness and all
is like the universe which surrounds him
nothing more or less than an
extraordinarily complex system of energy
Fields so-called states of matter are
actually variances in energy and human
consciousness is a function of the
interaction of energy
our Consciousness is tuned into the
frequencies of energy that make up the
world that we see but we only perceive a
small percentage of the energy that
actually exists all around us think of
tuning a radio if you tune into a rock
station you only hear music broadcast on
that channel now of course there are
lots of other channels with all
different kinds of music but your radio
doesn't play them all at once only the
single station it's tuned into our
brains are like that radio designed to
filter out everything except for the
energy that creates our reality and just
like a radio converts energy into sound
our brains convert this Universal energy
into things we can see and hear and
taste and touch but none of the solid
matter around us is actually there our
senses create the illusion of matter so
that we can experience this reality in a
way that we can understand now according
to the Gateway report we're all living
in a shared Universal hologram the
universe is composed of interacting
energy Fields it is in and of itself one
gigantic hologram of unbelievable
complexity according to the theories of
Carl prebroom a neuroscientist at
Stanford University and David boom a
physicist at the University of London
the human mind is also a hologram which
attunes itself to the universal hologram
and achieves the state which we call
consciousness
the Gateway process teaches you to turn
off the filter in your brain and gives
you access to alternate states of
reality and lets you escape space-time
altogether and anyone could learn to do
this you don't need to decalcify your
pineal gland or spend years at a
Buddhist monetary you don't need a
shaman or a guru or mind-altering drugs
you just need headphones the Gateway
process is done by listening to sound
but tell me more about this mindful
during drugs
[Music]
in the 1950s New York broadcasting
executive Robert Monroe found evidence
that different types of sound could
affect the human mind in different ways
some sound patterns would make you
sleepy another would make you alert some
sound can give you anxiety other sounds
are very relaxing well people have said
my voice is relaxing then you're not
reading the comments
using this discovery Monroe began
experimenting with hypnopedia or sleep
learning Monroe was convinced that there
was a connection between sound waves and
not just a person's mood but their
ability to learn and retain information
now one night while trying a sleep
learning technique Monroe had an
experience that was unexpected but would
change his life while listening to a
specific sound frequency his body slowly
became paralyzed he then started to feel
a vibration that became stronger and
stronger suddenly he was Awash in bright
white light then a sound or maybe just a
sensation of a rush of air that became a
roar so loud it was unbearable
yeah
then in an instant everything was quiet
the vibration stopped the light
dissipated and Robert Monroe found
himself in his bedroom floating above
his sleeping body there was no name for
this at the time but later became known
as an Obe an out-of-body experience a
term that Monroe himself popularized
though this Obe happened completely by
accident he was able to use sound to
replicate The Experience nine times over
the next six weeks Monroe wrote about
the experience in his 1971 book Journeys
out of the body he went on to found the
Monroe Institute and became a prominent
researcher in the field of human
consciousness Sue Monroe discovered that
while out of his body he could identify
access and sustain different states of
Consciousness this is done by
synchronizing the left and right
hemispheres of the brain now even though
the brain functions as a whole its
different parts serve different
functions as do its two hemispheres the
left hemisphere is traditionally
associated with logic and reason
perception and focus the right
hemisphere is possible for emotion
creativity and intuition so it's like a
sideways mullet sideways mullet what are
you talking about
business in the front but a party in the
back two pieces of your brainer like
that but a mullet is the front and back
and the brain is left and right so so
the mullet is sideways
I'm sorry all this about dimensions and
realities and mullets it's hard to
contribute
the left hemisphere of the brain tends
to be more active in the beta frequency
range of 13 to 30 Hertz which is
associated with alertness attention and
cognitive control the right hemisphere
is active in the alpha frequency range 8
to 13 Hertz which is associated with
relaxation creativity and spatial
processing the right brain operates much
more slowly than the left sideways
mullet by listening to certain sounds
the Gateway process synchronizes both
hemispheres using a technique called
Hennessy fundamentally the Gateway
experience is a training system designed
to bring enhanced strength focus and
coherence to the amplitude and frequency
of brainwave output between the left and
right hemispheres so as to alter
Consciousness moving it outside the
physical sphere so as to ultimately
Escape even the restrictions of time and
space the participant then gains access
to the various levels of intuitive
knowledge which the universe offers
the Gateway report describes hemisink as
a lamp versus a laser the natural state
of the human mind is like a lamp that
emits light but it's chaotic and messy
and uneven over large area hemisink lets
the Mind operate like a laser producing
a focused stream of energy according to
Gateway when the frequency and amplitude
of the human brain are brought into sync
it's possible to accelerate and raise
the vibrational levels of the Mind as
the Mind resonates higher and higher it
can synchronize with the more complex
energy levels in the universe at these
levels the mind is capable of processing
information in the same way it processes
the energy of our current reality in
other words you can see and feel and
understand these other states of reality
as easily as you understand this one but
you do more than understand reality you
can learn to change it control it and
bend it to your will like Neo in The
Matrix or like God
according to Colonel McDonald's Gateway
report understanding how human
consciousness could exist outside the
physical body requires an understanding
of holographic Theory or the holographic
principle uh-oh let me get my bucket
ready energy creates stores and
retrieves meaning in the universe by
projecting or expanding at certain
frequencies in a three-dimensional mode
that creates a living pattern called a
hologram
the report says that Holograms are
capable of encoding so much detail that
if you made a holographic projection of
a glass of swamp water you could put the
Hologram not the water the Hologram
under a microscope and see microscopic
organisms actually Holograms of
microscopic organisms now this sounds
nuts but the CIA was on to something
onto something big if you watched our
episode on simulation Theory you'll
remember John Wheeler and his delayed
Choice double slit experiment the video
has more details but in short wheeler
showed that particles seem to be able to
change their state by going back in time
now wheeler felt that the Universe
wasn't necessarily made up of matter and
energy but instead the universe is made
up of information our hologram uses this
information to create our
three-dimensional Universe a holographic
theory is a well-established idea in
theoretical physics and widely accepted
by many physicists I know it's a lot to
wrap your head around and I'd like to do
a whole episode on this so if you'd like
to see that email me or let me know in
the comments anyway in order to create
our hologram from information that
information has to be exchanged
particles can bounce off each other can
affect each other's speed carry energy
to each other and that's how they
exchange information but here's where
the Gateway report goes a step further
it says that this information can be
exchanged not just in our universe but
between Dimensions implying that there
are dimensions of reality yet to be
discovered his theory raises questions
about the interaction between human
consciousness and the holographic
Universe like can our Consciousness
which is energy also exchange
information with other dimensions the
Gateway process says that yes it can but
there's more McDonald argues that human
beings are not passive receivers of the
information floating around the universe
we participate in this information and
by training the way we perceive and
process the information that creates our
reality we can actually change reality
itself and this technique is called
patterning the technique of patterning
recognizes the fact that since
Consciousness is the source of all
reality our thoughts have the power to
influence reality if those thoughts can
be projected with adequate intensity
think about the concept of the secret
and the Law of Attraction which says
that we can make things happen by
focusing our imagination on a desirable
outcome but how how do we allow our
Consciousness to access this other
information the Planck distance is about
1.6 times 10 to the negative 35 meters
so really small it's the smallest
possible unit of length that has any
physical meaning in the universe at this
scale the laws of physics break down but
what if it's not the smallest in his
report Colonel MacDonald speculates that
by using the Gateway process to
accelerate brainwave frequencies humans
may be able to break the physical
limitation of the plight distance
McDonald suggests that Consciousness
could for an instant enter the space
beyond human perception it calls this
clicking out of reality it is true that
when for an infinitesimally brief
instant that energy reaches one of its
two points of rest it clicks out of time
space and joins Infinity
that critical step out of time space
occurs when the speed of the oscillation
drops below Planck's distance
to use the words of bent off quantum
mechanics tell us that when distances go
below Planck's distance we enter in
effect a new world
so I say we try it grab some headphones
and let's see what's out there
okay don't worry we're not really going
to escape reality at least not today I
just want to show you how the Gateway
process actually works the program
combines two techniques the first is
frequency following response or ffr ffr
involves introducing a frequency through
headphones which the brain tries to
mimic by adjusting its brain waves the
second technique is beat frequency you
might have heard this called binaural
beats this involves playing different
frequencies in each ear the brain then
chooses to hear the difference between
them for example The Sounds at four
Hertz are too low for you to hear but if
you listen to 100 Hertz through the
right ear and 104 Hertz in the left ear
your brain can detect and hear the
difference in this case or Hertz and
here's how it sounds
this is the left ear listen how the tone
is steady okay I'm with you please don't
talk during this part we're trying to
focus on the sound now a steady tone in
the right ear we play them together and
you can hear the oscillation between the
two frequencies like a vibrato
[Music]
I hear it you're gonna blow out their
ears sorry I get excited when I think
I'm gonna travel to other dimensions
remember your left brain is your logical
and analytical side before information
is processed by right brain which is the
emotional and creative side your left
brain takes a look at the information it
filters it and tries to make sense of it
before it accepts the information but
your right brain will happily absorb any
information thrown at it psychologists
like Ronald Stone say that hypnosis is a
technique that relaxes or distracts the
left brain so that outside stimuli have
direct access to the intuitive creative
right brain that's why people under
hypnosis are so impressionable they're
left logical brain is disengaged letting
everything through so if one of those
wacky hypnotists gets you to cluck like
a chicken it's because your left brain
isn't keeping tabs on the information
coming through and your right brain says
cluck like a chicken you got it your
right brain is always down to potty it
is the Gateway process relaxes the left
brain through sound waves when the brain
is relaxed enough the amplitude and
frequency of brain waves can be pushed
Higher and Higher and the space between
your brain waves gets smaller and
smaller and when the distance between
your brain waves drops below Planck's
distance it clicks out of space-time up
to this point our discussion of the
Gateway process has been relatively
simple and easy to follow easy for you
to say now the fun begins as the almost
continuous click out pattern establishes
itself in continuous phase at speeds
below Planck's distance but before
reaching the state of total rest human
consciousness passes through the looking
glass of time space after the fashion of
Alice beginning her journey into
Wonderland
but where is Wonderland well everything
is energy right look at McDonald's
drawing this represents our brain wave
or energy wave or Consciousness whatever
you want to call it it's all the same
thing the middle of the wave where it
spends most of its time is our reality
but at the bottom and the top of the
wave in that brief moment just before
the wave changes directions it isn't
moving at all it finishes going up it
stops then goes down stops very briefly
and then back up again it's at that
point where the wave changes direction
that it clicks out of our reality and
according to the Gateway report joins
infinity and the Absolute Energy in this
state of inactive Infinity is termed by
physicists as energy in its absolute
state or simply the absolute between the
absolute and the material Universe in
which we experience our physical
existence are various intervening
Dimensions to which human consciousness
in Altered States of being May gain
access since the absolute is conscious
energy and infinity that is without
boundaries it occupies every Dimension
to include the time space dimension in
which we have our physical existence but
we cannot perceive it
look I know it's not easy to follow but
think of it like this the top layer is
our reality everything that we can see
and touch that lays on top of these
other dimensions whatever they are and
all those dimensions and everything lays
on top of this thing McDonald calls the
absolute the absolute is everywhere but
we can't see it but everything happens
inside it so the absolute created our
world
but who created the absolute
well isn't it obvious you did
so how's your brain it's goo I'm on my
third bucket I know I told you this was
a Brain Buster so the absolute let me
try to keep it as simple as I can I'm
gonna need a glass absolute after this
episode pour me one too would you the
absolute is a conscious energy field at
rest
no it really is as simple as that the
absolute is an energy field that sits
there doing nothing but layered on top
of that energy field is the energy field
that makes up our reality and in between
those other dimensions but the absolute
is us we are the ones who created it and
everything else not one of us all of us
we're born into this reality where their
own individual Consciousness we live out
our time here on Earth and then our
Consciousness returns to the absolute
where it came from According to the
Gateway report we return to this
Collective Consciousness but we also
retain our individual identity so
immortality in a way Colonel McDonald
sees the absolute as what many people
might consider God the concept of
visible reality that is the created
world world as being an emanation of an
omnipotent and omniscient Divinity who
is completely unknowable in his primary
state of being the absolute at rest in
Infinity is a concept straight out of
Hebrew mystical philosophy even the
Christian concept of the Trinity shines
through the description of the absolute
as presented in this paper
McDonald also includes evidence of the
absolute and the universal hologram in
Eastern religions he quotes Tibetan
teachings and ancient Hindu texts the
colonel then goes on to describe the
nature of absolute itself and how it's
come to self-awareness how it relates to
all belief systems and all religions and
how no matter what you believe we're all
the same in order to attain
self-consciousness the consciousness of
the absolute must project a hologram of
itself and then perceive it the absolute
is the actual agent of all creation all
reality and the Eternal thought or
concept of self which results from this
self-consciousness serves the
what what happened serves the what well
that sentence is at the bottom of page
24 the document resumes on page 26 with
a whole different topic and then Colonel
McDonald wraps things up
CIA says they don't have it they don't
have the page that we Unite world eh
nope and they say they never did that's
that's
[Music]
foreign
people have been pressuring the CIA for
the missing page Voya requests have been
made petitions have been created all
trying to get the CIA to release page
25. the CIA insisted they don't have it
but in 2021 Vice published an article
about the Gateway document and mentioned
the controversy around the missing page
a few days later the Monroe Institute
released the complete report including
the mysterious page 25. what's on it
well I've linked to the complete
document below but the gist is this
McDonald's says that no matter what
religion or culture you're born into the
gateway process could be a valuable tool
if not the most valuable tool ever
designed to help a person truly
understand themselves and the nature of
the universe itself he says ancient
Mystics seem to understand the truth
about the universe intuitively and the
Gateway process confirms this everyone
on Earth is part of a collective
Consciousness all placed here for the
same purpose to accumulate experiences
to learn from one other and ultimately
take that knowledge back to the energy
for which we all came he says that if we
could become aware of this Universal
hologram we could free ourselves from
the prison of our individual lives and
finally realize that at our most basic
level we're all the same in a military
report right Colonel McDonald does
eventually get back to the Practical use
of an out-of-body experience with
respect to military strategy and
intelligence gathering but when I read
his report I feel like he gets back to
business because he has to otherwise
this document reads like he believes in
this process and believes it could
really help people interesting how this
page was dropped by the CIA huh yeah the
message of peace and unity was
conveniently absent from the cia's file
now I don't know if that was an accident
but I'm going to give them the benefit
of the doubt and say it was
but accident or not I agree it looks bad
McDonald ends his report by recommending
the army takes specific steps in
pursuing the Gateway process but they
should move in phases he recommends that
they use the Gateway tapes to learn how
to synchronize their brains using
hemisync then learn to induce the state
at will and once trainees can do this
they should learn to achieve an out of
body experience for remote viewing he
even gives some practical steps on how
to verify the information being viewed
is accurate he encourages anyone
learning the process to pursue
self-knowledge and remove any personal
prejudices that could be blocking their
progress the ultimate goal is patterning
that the military should learn to adjust
reality for what he calls practical
applications well that doesn't sound
good it doesn't when you read the
Gateway report you get the sense that
Colonel McDonald could be trusted with
this knowledge but the United States
military I don't know about that now you
could say the us only uses its military
power for National Defense
military or any government could be
trusted with the Gateway process my hope
is that as soldiers learn to access
these different states of Consciousness
they learn as McDonald did that the true
nature of the universe is Unity not
conflict you're quite The Optimist well
I try to be well here in the real world
optimists are always disappointed that's
true we are so thank goodness this isn't
the real world
[Music]
so what do you think about the Gateway
process is it just new age nonsense or
is there something to it are we just
living in one aspect of reality but with
training and patience we could explore
all of reality and if you do believe
there's something more out there that
the Gateway process could make available
to you would you try it now before you
answer you should know there are risks
now many students of the system have
said they've accessed these higher
planes of reality and their lives were
drastically improved they report more
self-awareness more creativity and
greater Clarity in their everyday lives
but some students have reported intense
anxiety depression and rare cases
psychosis whether you believe in the
Gateway process or not creating Altered
States Of Consciousness is absolutely
possible but when you do that there is
the potential to become detached from
this reality you could become untethered
and lost unable to find your way back
these negative outcomes are rare but
they do happen still McDonald
recommended that the military pursue the
Gateway process now I don't want to
reveal too much information but Colonel
McDonald is still around he's in his 80s
now and long retired and as far as I can
tell he never wrote about the Gateway
process again
but I'd really love to pick his brain to
see if he really believes in the Gateway
process to see if he's actually tried it
and if he did what did he see I like to
ask him if he fears death as many of us
do or if he's eager to rejoin the
absolute and contribute his experience
to our Collective Consciousness and as
he nears the end of his time in this
world does knowledge of the next World
give him peace I'd like him to tell me
that he's been to the other side and
there's nothing to be afraid of but the
Gateway process is true our
Consciousness is infinite and when we
die our energy returns to the absolute
now I'm not religious but this sounds a
lot like heaven and God now maybe not a
man in the sky with a boomy voice and a
white beard but God in the sense that we
all come from the same source so in a
way the Gateway process could prove the
existence of God or the afterlife but
people of Faith don't need proof but
scientists have no use for God they want
evidence they want scientifically
provable truth so as you're watching
this right now you might lean more
towards science or more toward God but
wouldn't it be amazing if they're
actually the same thing
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is AJ that's Heckle fish
this has been the Y files and if you had
butter learn anything do us a favor and
like subscribe comment share like
subscribe I know it's annoying but that
stuff actually really helps so like most
topics we cover here today's was
recommended by you I had never heard of
the Gateway process but now my mind is
blown and if this is a story you'd like
to see or learn more about go to the
yfiles.com tips special thanks to our
patrons who make all of this possible
you guys are amazing and if you'd like
to support the channel consider becoming
a member on patreon or grab something
from the Wi-Fi store oh we're doing
sideways mullet t-shirts right we're not
somebody's gonna ask for one I'm telling
you well we'll see I'm telling you
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
bye